so good morning a very good morning
please close the
door voila uh a very warm welcome here I
sure whether you were told that this is
the room where every Wednesday morning
the College of
Commissioners is meeting so the
so-called colleges uh take place here
and uh indeed we are are uh 20 we have
27 Commissioners as uh we have 27 member
states so it perfectly fits around this
table it is my very great pleasure to
welcome you today to the formal launch
of the structure dialogue for um the
Agriculture and the future of the
European
Union and um I put forward this idea um
in my state of the union Last Summer
and I think we all sense that there is
an
increasing Division and polarization
when it comes to topics re um relevant
and um related to Agriculture and I'm
deeply convinced that we can only
overcome this polarization that we all
sense by dialogue we've discussed this
yesterday evening this is the reason why
we want to bring together around this
table a pretty diverse group of actors
of Europe's Agri food sector and I'm
very glad to see you all here I'm glad
to see representatives from our Farmers
Farm Workers rural
communities who are the custodians of
our best traditions and who bring life
to our
Countryside we have also the industries
around the table you who put the food on
the table we have members of consumers
and environmental groups because all of
society cares about the countryside and
cares about our
food but also the financial
sector and um the Academia are here in
this room so indeed a very diverse group
but all stakeholders in the same field
and I'm sure that in the coming days and
weeks we will have many more
stakeholders that will send us our
thoughts their thoughts their ideas
their proposals they will share their
ideas with us and we want to
listen and ask you to discuss and to
develop scenarios for the
future basically it is about describing
the way forward and I want first and
foremost to thank all of you that you
are dedicating your really precious time
with us and that you're also sharing
your expertise and your knowledge and
hopefully your ideas for the future with
us yesterday evening I very much liked
our start at the informal
dinner and um what I took away from the
meeting yesterday or the informal dinner
yesterday evening is that we all have
the same sense of
urgency that things have to
improve and that we have to find a new
way forward
and common and Lasting solutions for the
problems that you're all very much aware
of you will discuss under the leadership
of professor
strosnider professor strosnider let me
once again thank you very much um that
you're having accepted this challenge uh
this is um wonderful and I'm very
grateful for
that now your task your task is of
crucial
importance it is thanks to to European
agriculture that is the man and woman
who work the land that Europe has the
healthiest and the highest quality food
in the world our Farmers operate on a
daily basis in a very competitive Global
Market you are often the most vulnerable
part um in the value chain and of course
you deserve a fair
renumeration our aim is to support your
livelihoods and to guarantee European
food
security each of you have a role to play
each of you from of course your own
perspective consumers will have a ro
role to play as their choices Drive
Innovation and demand parents for
example are looking for healthy food for
their children they choose very
carefully young people increasingly ask
for more sustainable food food retailers
and processors are equally crucial
you have to compete
globally and you have to act
locally you are responding to Consumer
preferences many of you stand up for
animal welfare and
biodiversity and many of you defend the
interests of the well less of for
example by fighting food waste I
listened very carefully to you
yesterday and it is thanks to all of you
each and everyone at his or her place
that we have to overcome the difficult
um questions ahead of us but it's also
thanks to all of you and each and
everyone that we did overcome already
very difficult times if we think back at
the pandemic or at the energy crisis or
the food crisis both triggered by the
Russian aggression in Ukraine we have
also suffered from high inflation both
um agricultur inputs and food were
affected by that so we had already
difficult times to overcome together and
it is amazing to see that Europe's Agri
food sector showed a remarkable
resilience in all of
this in addition we are all making
tremendous efforts to contribute to our
Collective goals of the European green
deal it's
existential because we all live with
nature we all live from nature and while
we certainly may not always see eye to
eye on all issues we all agree that the
challenges are without any question
mounting now be it the competition from
abroad be it overregulation at
home be it climate change or the loss of
biodiversity or be it demographic
decline just to name a few of the
challenges we have been also discussing
yesterday what are food in Europe needs
is a long-term perspective to face these
challenges predictable Way
Forward and to forge this way
forward that is your task the task of
the 27 individuals that are here in this
room I hope that you will build the
trust to appreciate each other's
perspectives and to find common
solutions for the future of agriculture
in
Europe this dialogue aims to find a new
consensus on issues which we all
struggle with for example how can we
Elevate the standard of living for
farmers and the attractiveness of rural
communities how can agriculture be
sustainable within the planetary
boundaries how can we better harness
knowledge and
technology how can we enhance Europe's
food system for a competitive thriving
Future these are just some of the
questions that we are
facing now finding a
consensus and a common way a common view
on the way forward is certainly not an
easy task I'm fully aware of that but I
also think it is an immense opportunity
that we have here an opportunity to
shape the future
and an essential part of the economy of
tomorrow it's an opportunity to preserve
an essential part of our European Soul
our way of
life because we all depend on our
country side and we all live with nature
and in
nature so today I want to ensure you
that the vision or perhaps the advice or
the concrete
recommendations that you will agree on
by summary
will impact the work of the coming
years I trust
you I rely on your expertise and on your
knowledge your ideas I'm very much
looking forward to working for you with
you and um I'm wishing all of us B
courage good luck um and a lot of trust
in the coming weeks and months for this
um important work thank you very
much
[Applause]
and with that I would hand over the
floor to officially Professor
Schneider and from now I'm I'm in a
listening mode and you're the
boss thank you thank you very much
Madame President for the honor
to invite us for the honor to open your
house for
this very important
Endeavor Madame President ladies and
gentlemen dear members of the Strategic
dialogue the task that the president of
the commission has set us is by no means
trivial on the contrary it's quite
challenging on the one hand because the
four main questions that will guide our
dialogue incompass numerous and very
complex and also controversial
aspects the perspectives of European
farmers and Rural
communities are by no means uniform in
economic
terms we will have to think very
seriously about how the very
differentiated forms of European
agriculture can be related to planetary
and ecological
boundaries scientific and technological
innovation in Mech mechanical and
genetic engineering in digitization and
agrochemicals will offer enormous
opportunities but at the same time will
hardly be available without any risk
which will have to be shaped socially
and politically we will have to describe
food security and nutrition quality in
Europe in global contexts in global
contexts and trading systems which are
corre
IED by a plethora of rapidly changing
tasks and geopolitical conflicts of
interest on the other hand these issues
are linked to an overarching goal which
the president has described as
overcoming polarization in Agricultural
and environmental politics through our
common
dialogue which she has described as
reconciling which is not a trivial word
itself uh which has which he has
described as reconciling economic
competitiveness and responsible climate
nature and Environmental Protection in
all of this it cannot be
overlooked and I therefore do not want
even to conceal it it cannot be
overlooked that our mandate leads right
into the middle of a compr apprehensive
process of civilizational change for
this the term great transformation
became widely in use and of course such
a massive transformation will not
succeed without major
conflicts such conflicts can be seen for
example in the protests by farmers in
numerous European countries right now or
in the youth climate movement or in the
apocalyptic semantics that are often
prominent Farm death climate death
species ex Extinction this is a sort of
death semantics that dominates public
discourse on our problem field major
conflicts which can also seen in changes
of society's attitudes towards
agriculture brought about by major
structural and economic changes in
agriculture and rural areas brought
about by public debates on Environmental
Protection nature convers conservation
climate mitigation animal protection and
the economic prospects of
farms major conflicts that can also be
seen in the fact that debates about
different nutritional styles are
increasingly taking on the fervor of
cultural battles
it is within this framework which I only
sketch out here in a few lines that we
want to try to develop a consensual
draft a common Vision a proposal for the
further development for the future
development of European Agricultural and
food and food industry
policies a proposal that is convincing
or at least acceptable to the various
stakeholders and that is not without any
concrete political impact in the end and
let me express my great trait gratitude
to all of you for embarking on this
somewhat adventurous common Journey over
the next few months this journey will
take us through all kinds of shallows
and it is probably not at all risky to
predict some of the areas of conflict in
which we feel in which we will find
ourselves along the
way we will probably have to discuss how
agriculture food nutrition from Plants
to Meat and Fish trade rural uh rural
energy rural environments energy and
environmental policies how these Pol
policies should actually be organized
organized so that Agricultural and
environmental policy do not not
perceive each other in a win lose
constellation in which an environmental
policy success is always an agricultural
policy defeat and vice
versa how these policies should be
organized so that agricultural landscape
is not decisive only for rural areas but
for our view on Europe and on the
surface the face of Europe Europe so
that competition becomes a broad field
as it is increasingly important in the
Agricultural and Food Systems to balance
quality and quantity competition and
extend this not only to product quality
but also to process quality of food
production to shape these policies so
that it does not exclusively promote
expansion of farm units and Fields or
freezing
structures and intensification and
standardization of production forms or
marketing standards and uniformity of
regional agricultural
structures but that these policies
rather develop resilient diversity of
formats and types of agricultural
production from business models to crop
rotation to the structural richness of
the agricultural landscape in vital
rural
areas how to shape these policies so
that they make cost
externalization including the overuse of
the commons that they may cost
externalization as difficult as possible
and make
reinternalization of external costs more
likely of course here as in all other
questions the devil is in the detail in
the questions of balancing conflicting
goals and conflicting interests in the
development of political interventions
in the adjustment of their intended
effects and their unanticipated side
effects in administration implementation
legal structures impact monitoring and
so forth and so
forth we will presumably not be able to
to disc discuss all of this all of these
detailed question that we come across on
our adventure trip and we certainly
won't be able to entirely solve them at
firsthand nevertheless I'm convinced
that the Strategic dialogue we are
starting today that it can succeed and
that it can become a success a success
for the future of European
agriculture to explain my confidence in
this at least a little please allow me
to make four brief comments on our
prospects first
remark most of you unlike the chairman
have particular expertise in various
issues relating to agriculture food and
Environmental Protection nevertheless
the dialogue is not an expert commission
if by experts we mean if I if by experts
we mean neutral Specialists without
direct vested
interests
basically as members of the
dialogue you do not have the sole
Mandate of being appointed at personam
by the president of the European
commission rather you the members
represent at the same time the
organization to which you belong in a
leading position and the interests that
are organized in these
organizations the members are therefore
not only subject to the obligation to
provide factual justification for your
statements but also to justify them in
terms of organizational
policies you you must therefore be able
to withstand the tangents arising from
this because only then does the
Strategic dialogue have a chance of
success if we can somehow break away
from the traditions of previous battles
if all members are prepared to rethink
the established positions of their
respective
organizations I would like this to
summarize in the following sentence the
logic of the Strategic dialogue as
undeniably knowable knowledge ible you
all are the logic of the Strategic
dialogue is not the pooling of technical
expertise the logic is the sensible
social and political balancing of
conflicting economic ecological and
social
interests which all you have in a
different
waiting I see us if you
like as a forum for balancing these
interests and among other things this
also means we are not a day-to-day
political monitoring body politics is
going
on while we convene we are not a
day-to-day political monitoring body
that could be used to intervene in EU
policy in the coming months or in the
European election campaign rather we are
undertaking an open movement for medium
and long-term processes and in this
respect it is not bad at
all that at least the chairman does not
already have the solution to all the
problems in
mind second remark it is possible to
balance diverging interests sensibly and
fairly even in
particular difficult areas and this does
not require to entirely reinvent Agri
environmental policies there is a wealth
of knowledge in science and also in
administration that we can that we can
build upon but it requires us to find
conceptual Pathways that we can agree on
despite all the differences in
interests this will be easier if we do
not concentrate on the individual often
ideologically exagger at points of
conflict and by the way ideology as a
wise Englishman said is like bad breath
only the others have
it it is
not it will not be or will hard be to
find conceptual
Pathways if we it will be easier to find
um conceptual Pathways if we
concentrate on developing something like
a systemic systematic framework into
which we then can categorize the
individual issues and which enables us
to
reconciliate conflicting interests not
in each individual detail but across the
spectrum of
issues and this would be make us able
to no this would would this would us
enable to make the role of
reto players more difficult in this
round the considerable challenge for the
Strategic dialogue therefore is to
organize the balancing of positions and
interests and I think that we should try
to do so for a medium time Horizon let's
say 5 to 15 years which mean more than
the next commission has to deal with or
two future multiannual ual Frameworks so
to
say and we should try to find a medium
level of concretia of concretization for
this and by a medium level of
concretization I
mean
between two general formula compromises
like do the good and avoid the evil
which we are easily would be able to
agree on but which remain politically
irrelevant and
inconsequential between two general
formula compromises on the one hand side
and the incalculable number of detailed
issues of often extremely detailed
issues that can then only be dealt with
in selective deals which often lead into
deadlock situations I mean you all of
you know these type of deals glyphosate
ban 10 10 15 years later but flow strips
by 7 M50 instead of only 5 m 35 or so
this type of deals of detailed deals we
will not be able to solve but we will be
able to develop a framework in which
then this type even this type of deals
could be solved by those responsible for
it in a political and administrative way
we should do so on a medium time level
and a
medium a medium level of concretization
we should do so in order to be able to
formulate reasonable recommendations for
a truly sustainable further development
of Agriculture which can then also
become politically
impactful third remark reconciling
economic competitiveness with ecological
respons responsibility in a social
responsible agriculture within rural
areas of the future this is what the
president has underlined before if we
want to take this
seriously and we
should then this means discussing how
competitiveness can be achieved not
against the protection of Nature and the
climate ed through negative external
externalities
not against the protection of Nature and
climate but by means of it and vice
versa this means discussing how the
protection of the environment and
climate can be strengthened not at the
exent of
competitiveness but but with with its
help we must therefore not play
competitiveness and preservation of
nature playing them off against each
other by but make them useful for each
other and that means I would assume that
we need to identify development paths
for a future agriculture that are
likewise microeconomic viable on the
level of farms and
companies
macroeconomic
beneficial
ecologically responsible and therefore
also acceptable to those affected and
socially feasible to formulate this
crucial Point once again in a different
way we have to take into account
that economic ecological and social
viability as well as social acceptance
is needed at the same time these
criteria the three dimensions of
sustainability according to the um
sdgs these three D dimensions of
sustainability do not form a ranking
order they are of equal importance
otherwise there would be no need for a
strategic dialogue because politics
could derive its Solutions directly from
the ranking order of these normative
framework so to
say and these criteria are associated
with a wealth of conflicting of
objectives factual differences of
opinion conflicts of interest and also
conflicts of power of power of
course fourth
remark I'm firmly convinced that we can
overcome the many challenges facing the
Strategic Dialogue on the future of
agriculture in Europe however I am
really
convinced that we will only be able to
do so if we succeed in creating a common
space of trust and
confidentiality this would be a space in
which I can recognize that opposing
positions may also have reasonable
grounds a space in which it is not a
defeat to try an argument once that
turns out not to be of any use in the
further
discussion a space of trust and
confidentiality in which we are all able
to take the perspective of the other
side in which we are all able to once
and again take a step back from our own
position so that we
realize that our own views are not
entirely free of internal contradictions
and tension the others do see these
internal contradictions and intentions
anyhow what I'm saying here may seem a
little pathetic at first basically
ladies and
gentlemen basically however it is simply
what we all have to constantly demand of
each other in open pluralistic societies
and liberal democracies it's an everyday
undertaking in pluralistic democracies
to be able to take the position of the
other I don't want to say much more at
the beginning let's started let's get
started this adventurous Endeavor and if
after we have exchanged our basic
positions if we would get to a point
today where we are able to formulate the
very first perspectives that are
compatible with my position and of which
I can also assume at the same time that
everyone else would perhaps going along
with them if we would meet that point
even today then we would have made the
best possible start in our collaboration
that you might imagine thank you very
much thank you handing back to you no
no I I I think I so thank you very much
first of all